[تصفيق]
حشد كبير جدًا
سنقوم بسحق الفيروس ،
شكرًا جزيلاً لك لم يكن أحد
يرتدي أقنعة في
الغرفة عندما كنا نعد الرئيس
خلال تلك الفترة الزمنية
وكنا نحن المجموعة كانت
حوالي خمسة أو ستة أشخاص في  إجمالي
[تصفيق]
عليك أن تفهم ما إذا كنت تنظر ،
أعني أن لدي قناعًا هنا ، أضع
قناعًا عليه ، كما تعلم عندما أعتقد
أنني بحاجة إليه ، لا أرتدي فوضى مثله في كل
مرة تراه لديه قناع
يمكن أن يتكلم على بعد
200 قدم منه يظهر
بأكبر قناع رأيته على الإطلاق ،
حسنًا ، شكرًا جزيلاً ، نحن ذاهبون إلى
مينيسوتا
[موسيقى]
[موسيقى] ظهرت
بعض الأخبار في وقت سابق من هذا المساء ، آه
أمل هيكس الذي عمل لديه
لقد أثبتت إصابتك بفيروس كورونا لفترة طويلة
وخرجت للتو لإجراء اختبار وسأرى
ما تعرفه لأننا قضينا الكثير من
الوقت في السيدة الأولى خرجت للتو
مع اختبار أيضًا ،
سواء كنا في الحجر الصحي أو ما إذا كنا
لدي لا أعرف
[موسيقى]
لك